The Joe Rogan experience,
Jimmy.
Oh,
and I look at your search engine.
I would take away your right to vote.
I'd be like,
there's no way I got different computers.
Like what's wrong with you?
That's why I got different little creek.
That's why I got different computers,
you know,
to see my other ones,
Dan,
I don't want anybody know I have different emails.
This is Mr happy.
Mr. Happy likes to get on this one.
He only looks for happy thing.
Flowers,
different personality for different computers.
Lawn mower was Mr dirty.
This is what I really like.
I liked the best organic fertilizer.
It doesn't hurt the environment.
You do your computer live in La.
Where would you live?
And if we,
we all moved together,
where should we go to questions?
Either.
Well,
it's gotta be somewhere.
There's no state income tax because you're tired of this shit.
Tired of this bullshit.
What if you start making more money?
You don't do it.
Fuck anymore.
Yeah,
but still,
it's kind of like,
why am I paying any more money to the fucking plenty of homeless people around.
Okay.
All right,
fine.
Someone's going to fix the streets too.
Are they?
What are they going to start?
It looks good.
That's why a lot of athletes operate out of Florida.
I drove here today and it didn't bother me at all.
Yeah.
You live so close to here.
I live on the roof live in Florida because of low income tenants.
Operate your business out of this is why.
Oh,
Jay's.
They're like,
they can't get you if you owe money to Florida.
Kit Kat.
You,
yeah,
you can hide in Florida if you owe money.
Really?
Yeah.
It's one of them weird ones.
So I've Trump nationals down there.
Well,
I think that's like pensions and shit.
Like they can't take away your pensions.
Right?
They probably have some weird like union restriction law that they can't touch
your stuff.
I think.
I don't really,
I don't know if I could live in Florida,
but yeah,
you could.
Yeah.
You would just mock it.
Me and oatmeal and John Travolta and he lives in a collar.
We're right next door to him.
He always offer massages and shit and you'd be like,
Nah,
I'm good.
I'm gonna jump on it together.
Let's you and me just fly.
Fuck.
Dunno man.
John Travolta wants to be my friend.
Do you think he just wants to be my friend?
He just said,
buddy,
he's a good guy.
He's got a exclaim.
Oh No,
we have to land in the water.
We'll have to hold each other for warmth for awhile.
Oh,
how long?
For like four days maybe inside you and keep you warmer from the inside by Dixon
your ass.
They might come respites astrons very hot.
I know it sounds crazy,
but it's a different shape of life and death.
Got to put it inside.
If you put your mouth on my penis,
it,
you'll see it's like over a hundred degrees comes up,
blow me up and then ride me as we float away.
Blow me up like a balloon.